-Good evening, I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We're happy to have you with us,
and now if you don't mind,
we're gonna get to the news.
President Biden hosted the NBA
champion Golden State Warriors
today at the White House,
where they gave him
an honorary jersey,
and he gave them the location
of Israel's nukes.
"Oh, wait, hold on.
I'm gonna need those back."
[ Laughter ]
The White House said yesterday
that it does not keep
visitor logs
for President Biden's personal
residence in Delaware.
If you want to know who visited,
you'll just have to watch
"Jay Leno's Garage."
[As Leno] Eh, I think these are
classified documents.
[ Laughter ]
[Normal voice]
Thank you, it was very...
Oh, yeah.
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Laughter ]
Alabama and Mississippi
yesterday observed
a state holiday that honors
Dr. Martin Luther King Jr.
and Confederate general
Robert E. Lee.
I'm sorry, did I say "and"?
Because I definitely meant "or."
[ Laughter ]
"I like 'em both!"
In a new episode of a podcast,
former President Trump said
that he heard Florida governor
Ron DeSantis may challenge him
for the Republican presidential
nomination, and added, quote,
"We'll handle that
the way I handle things."
So get ready, Ron --
he's gonna cheat on you.
[ Laughter ]
That's how he do.
[ Cheers and applause ]
When asked in a new interview
about Senate Minority Leader
Mitch McConnell,
Louisiana Senator John Kennedy
said that McConnell
is an enigma,
and added that he, quote, "saw
him smile once back in 2017."
Said McConnell, "I remember it.
It was at the end
of 'Marley & Me.'"
[ Laughter ]
[As McConnell]
That was very, uh...
That Marley finally got
what was coming to him.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cackles as McConnell ]
[Normal voice]
Prince William visited
the charity Together As One
today for a cooking lesson
and shared his favorite
cake recipe --
"tell someone
to make you a cake."
[ Laughter ]
[ Chuckles ]
Missouri DMV officials recently
released a list
of the 500 vanity license plates
that were rejected last year,
including one that read "GOTAZZ"
on the grounds
of false advertising.
[ Laughter ]
The only reason I picked
that joke today --
the writers also describe what
they want in the key over here,
and the writer wrote,
"A man with a flat ass,
shot in profile."
And I was curious if it would be
clear that he'd got no "azz,"
and, uh...
totally is.
[ Laughter ]
Today was talk show host
Maury Povich's 84th birthday,
so pretty safe to say
he's not the father.
[ Laughter ]
That joke has a flat ass.
And finally, according
to a new report,
three NFL teams are considering
pursuing quarterback Tom Brady
when he becomes a free agent,
not to mention about
a dozen bocci leagues.
And that was a monologue,
everybody.